everybody what is going on welcome to
yet another PI game tutorial video and
another part of our little mini series
of drawing buttons with PI game where we
left off we've got the button it's
interactive in the sense that when we
hover over it the button lights up as if
it could be clicked or something can be
done with it and now we want to do is
talk about how might we put text on the
button so we can actually treat the
button very much like we've treated our
game display when we throw text to it
and again like I said in the last video
we will build a button function have no
fear but for now I just want to show you
guys the logic that we're kind of
putting into it and then we'll throw it
all into a button function so let's go
ahead and get started here so right now
we're just basically lighting up the
green button and then we'll throw text
to the green button and then we'll do
everything to the red button afterwards
once we have an actual button function
so to put text on our button how might
we do that well all we need to do is we
need to know the the coordinates of our
button and then how Y does the button
how tall is the button divide that all
by two and center the rect of our text
object on that done same thing that
we're doing with putting messages to the
game display so easy enough we'll go
ahead and do that again I do recommend
that eventually you put like up at the
very top and we've got all of our
constants have some like small text
medium text large text that we don't
have to redefine it every time but for
now we'll just redefine it to put up
small text I guess it's a good idea to
just walk through it again anyways I'm
sure we could probably find this has
been one of our things like this
probably will run through it one more
time just to solidify anyways after all
we're trying to teach plugin so right
here is what will do it so we're going
to say small text and small text is
going to equal PI game dot font dot
capital F font and then what font do we
want to use we'll just use a free sans
old dot TTFN and what size do we want
make it 24 sets its small then we know
that text surface and text rect is going
to equal text underscore objects and
then what do we want the message to be
for the green button and since it's like
a racy game why don't we have it to go
green means go after all
and then the text objects again that's a
function we built so we come up here and
this is our text objects we've got text
objects text and font and then it
returns the surface and then the
rectangle so we'll come down here and go
and then we throw in the fonts basically
so that's small text now we need to
Center this so how do we do that well
this is going to be text rect
dot Center equals and this is a little
more confusing especially because we're
hard coding it but don't worry we'll non
hard to code it in a little bit but
basically we Center it on the X first so
how we some of the X well that will be
150 so that's the x-coordinate plus um
how tall was this again or I mean so I'm
sorry how wide was this again well it's
100 pixels wide right so that would be
150 plus a 100 but then half of that
would be what well 111 2 so that's the
center of our I'm sorry the center of
our X and then how do we Center the Y
and in fact when we case this that so
that's our X this is X comma now how do
we Center Y well we know it starts at
450 and then it's 50 pixels tall so plus
50 divided by 2 and that is how we'll
will Center the Y let's just check the
parentheses there everything closes off
so that's good
and now all we need to do is go game
game display dot bêlit what do we blitt
the text text surface um text surf bug
and then text reps and that should
Center up go over our button so save and
run that real quick and sure enough now
we have go over our button and it's
still slightly interactive as we hover
over it and all that fun stuff cool so
we've got that going for us
we've basically defines um everything we
need we just the only thing remaining
now is when we click the button that it
does something and I think I'll save
that for once we actually create the
button function so in the next video
what we're going to do is go ahead and
create a bunch button function so check
that out and as always thanks for
watching thanks for all the support
subscriptions until next time